[Music]
hey what's going on and welcome back hot
ones fans spring is in the air and we
are heating things up with our season 18
hot sauce lineup but before we get
started you may have noticed in the
corner of the video a donation button
for hot ones charity cause common
threads
during the holiday extravaganza with
gordon ramsay you guys showed up big and
set a fundraising record with nearly 150
000 for their end of year drive
as we get closer to summer common
threads is hard at work to make sure
that kids have healthy nutritious food
options even when school is out of
session we were blown away by the
holiday extravaganza our fans so
generous if you're able if you're
willing please consider a donation to
make sure that the kids are set as we
approach summer and speaking of summer
and heating things up let's dive in to
the season 18 lineup and leading things
off it's old trusty the blue label the
classic garlic fresno
the return of the classic garlic fresno
edition in the lead off position tartan
tangy vinegar an extra hit of garlic and
then fresh fresno chilies grown from the
fire roasted fields of smokin ed curry's
farm it's the classic for a reason the
blue label in the one spot alright
moving on to number two one of our
favorite hawaiian makers is back
here we are in the two spot with this
mild and tropical fire roasted pineapple
number fittingly named island wing sauce
the cayenne peppers are blended to silky
smooth perfection and then the
caramelization of the pineapples that's
that
chef's kiss touch that sets adobo loco
apart all right moving on to number
three now remember last season number
two ridiculously spicy for number two
sauce this season i think that the front
half wild card is actually in the three
spot
with a triumphant return to the lineup
after their season 7 debut it's burns
and mccoy's mezcalene
the name actually refers to mezcal in
the recipe that adds a smoky note to a
complex blend of espresso orange
habanero and chocolate ghost pepper
powder
a spicy number three if ever i've tasted
one all right an old friend in the four
spot holding it down los calientes verde
the sauce of summer is back with tangy
tomatillo smoky serranos and a hint of
cumin
lose calientes verde has that goldilocks
heat just right for spice heads and
spiced noobs alike all right moving on
to the midway point it's the sauce
leopard from denver colorado sauce
leopard welcome to the party
the seventh reaper channels the flavors
of argentina with the red chimichurri
style sauce packed with savory roasted
red peppers tomato and garlic and as the
name would suggest there's a little bit
of carolina reaper in there as well sure
to have some guests wondering what the
hell they signed up for as they explain
their grams all right moving on to the
number six sauce hot and saucy returns
to kick off the back half
you know when you douse your collard
greens in hot sauce and it's the perfect
pairing for a plate of fried chicken
chef sam of hot and saucy and harlem has
bottled that flavor memory perfectly but
with significantly more scovilles thanks
to liberal use of ghost peppers that is
hot and saucy collard and ghost in the
six spot and then in the seventh spot we
welcome to the table our first ever
maker from south dakota
tirfin's curse from hollow ghee hot
sauce leaves tongues writhing in pain
with a wicked combo of habanero ghost
and scorpion peppers but the bright
flavors of turmeric citrus and ginger
they help light the path to the number
eight sauce where to bomb beyond
insanity waits and pray
dizzy and discombobulating to bomb
beyond insanity picks off its victims as
they climb the upper reaches of mount
scoville it's nasty
it's gross it has no redeeming culinary
qualities whatsoever but it is very hot
impossible to outrun and it has a legacy
and reputation that is bigger than the
hot sauce lineup itself to bomb beyond
insanity
build the statue it stays all right
moving on to number nine a hot sauce
called psycho with a scoville rating of
666 000
could not be more australian
dingo sauce companies widowmaker did gas
dirty on season 11 and this blend of
some of the world's hottest peppers
including trinidad moruga scorpion it's
sure to do the same all right and then
moving on to number 10 the last dab
apollo i like to call it the gold label
the special potion that brings our show
to a close you don't have to if you
don't want to but you know what i will
and there you have it another hot sauce
lineup is in the books if any of these
sauces have piqued your interest or
you'd like to play along at home
heatness.com.com.com to get your hands
on the season 18 hot sauce lineup and
before we kick off season 18 it's time
to do one last check in with camera guy
bill during the off season before we put
him back to work behind that camera that
i'm gesturing to right now but in the
meantime bill what do you have going on
oh hey there sean as you know every off
season i like to learn a new skill
perfect a new craft and even make some
new friends along the way but this off
season i decided to bring things back to
basics and focus on myself i decided to
find my inner kid again
i've been skipping
[Music]
i bought a scooter
i've been drawing
i've really been taking it easy
getting back in touch with younger bill
has reminded me how awesome my childhood
was thanks mom and dad and to make sure
other kids have the same chance to
thrive i'm supporting common threads
common threads uses nutritional
education chef-led cooking courses and
grocery store tours to make sure kids
have the proper fuel to learn play and
grow
if you'd like to make a difference to
support an awesome cause smash that
donate button on the side of this video
back to you sean
well thanks so much for that bill
amazing as always alright we have a
blockbuster season of hot ones coming to
you very soon may 26th in fact that's
right hot ones rides again may 26th with
a very special premiere a guest a return
guest who have been patiently waiting to
see again in the hot seat this is rare
but you're here you've made it this long
in the video i think it's time to give
you a treat
colin roll the tape
it's it is hot
it is hot i lied maybe i need to stand
up
am i in frame
we'll find you
is it worse than you remember you got a
tough gig
it's very worse than that
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience and one convenient package
i'm proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
hot ones boneless chicken bites it's a
party in a bag and everyone's invited
[Music]